Sarah Huckabee Sanders gets denied
dinner Maxine Waters goes
philosophically fascist and George will
goes too far I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
man over the weekend I turned to my wife
and I said I am exhausted by the news
cycle and then the rest of the news
cycle hits that was awesome
lots of stuff to talk about today
apparently you can't go anywhere for
dinner now which is kind of frightening
we will get to all of that first I want
to mention that we have a special
livestream coming up Monday July 2nd at
7 p.m. Eastern it's our July 4th special
we will be joined by special guest
Jordan Peterson to celebrate
Independence Day god-king jeremy boring
will host a new edition of daily wire
backstage with me and andrew Clavin and
michael knowles to look back on our
country's birth and look ahead to its
future subscribers will even be able to
write in live questions for us to answer
on the air jordans gonna be sitting in
with us as well that is Monday July 2nd
7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific with
Jordan Peterson and you can find our
special live stream on Facebook and
YouTube so don't miss it also before we
get started I want to mention our
sponsors over at Zeile so there are
certain things in life as I've said many
many times that make you feel wealthy
without actually having to be wealthy
well Zeile is one of those things
because you're at home after a long day
of work and your back hurts and you're
thinking okay maybe I need to schedule a
massage over at the spa but if I do that
it's gonna take me a week to get in
there and then it's gonna be really
expensive and I don't know who's gonna
be massaging me anyway well that's where
Zeile comes in Zeile calm ze e L calm
allows you to select from top local
licensed pre-screened massage therapists
you can choose your favorite technique
gender preference time and location for
your massage its on-demand
and Zeile sends you one of their 10,000
licensed massage therapists with a
massage table and music and supplies
they do the whole thing right in your
house a 5-star massage right in your
apartment or your house scheduling
booking payment fast and easy even the
tip is included 7 days a week 365 days a
year
Zeile massage therapists can be at your
door in as little as an hour I've used
it for myself for my wife for my
mother-in-law for my parents for my
sister like it's become a very popular
thing in our family a popular gift we
give to one another over at Zeile calm
with the seal app there's a reason that
seal has been featured in The Wall
Street Journal New York Times Vogue and
on Good Morning America to help you get
started our listeners get a $25 discount
off their first massage with promo code
Benton that ze e el comp remote command
in right now again go to Zeile comm and
when you use that promo code Ben then
you get 25 bucks off your first in-home
massage it really is spectacular so go
check that out ok so over the weekend we
decided we can't live in the country
with each other very very exciting stuff
it turns out that we no longer want to
eat dinner with one another we no longer
want to serve one another I'm not
talking about people who have
objections to participating in the
same-sex wedding I'm talking about if I
don't like your political viewpoint you
are not allowed to enter my restaurant
now as I've said before it's a free
country you can do whatever you want you
don't want me to eat in your restaurants
I'm a Republican that's your business
you want to ban me from your private
college campus like you did it to Paul
University that's your business right
it's a free country you can do that does
it make for a better country no and I do
want to distinguish here between trying
to force somebody to participate via
governmental intervention in somebody
else's activity and whether something is
good or not so as I've said many times I
think that as a general rule you should
serve everybody who comes into your
establishment I don't think that
necessarily means you have to serve
everybody who comes into your
establishment I don't think that means
that you must serve people who want
special privileges or they want you to
participate in a ceremony that you feel
is immoral but I do think that as a
general rule just as a good person if I
owned an establishment I would service
you if you came into my establishment
I wouldn't service the same-sex wedding
because I have moral objections to a
same-sex wedding just as many of these
bakers and photographers do but if I
owned a restaurant like chick-fil-a I
would allow anybody to eat there just as
chick-fil-a does and I think that is the
moral thing to do I think that is the
right thing to do again you have the
freedom to reject anybody so there's
been a big brouhaha over the weekend
because it turns out that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders went to a restaurant called the
red hen in Lexington Virginia and
Stephanie Wilkinson who's the owner of
the redhead in Lexington asked the press
secretary to leave the restaurant on
Friday evening she told she apparently
took a staff vote before privately
asking Sanders to leave the restaurant
and Sanders replied that's fine I'll go
one diner posted an image of 86 next to
her name industry slang for kick-out so
the owner of the red hen restaurant has
revealed why she refused to serve the
White House press secretary on Friday
night Sanders was asked to leave the
Lexington Virginia restaurant where she
was dining with her seven family members
and restaurant owner Stephanie Wilkinson
said she took a staff vote before asking
Sanders to leave when they voted to boot
her out Wilkinson complied tell me what
you want me to do I can ask her to leave
and they said yes so apparently she
started texting to all of her employees
about it she said I'm not a huge fan of
confrontation I have a business and I
want the business to thrive this feels
like the moments in our democracy when
people have to make uncomfortable
actions and decisions to uphold their
morals well this doesn't really uphold
your morals to throw somebody out of
your restaurant if you disagree with
them politically but you know again it's
free country you can
what you want well Sarah Huckabee
Sanders then tweeted out about this and
she tweeted out what exactly happened
and she didn't call for a boycott
against the restaurant she said last
night I was told by the owner of the red
hen in Lexington Virginia to leave
because I work for the President and I
politely left her actions say far more
about her than about me
I always do my best to treat people
including those I disagree with
respectfully and will continue to do so
so they're a bunch of separate issues we
need to separate out here one is it bad
to throw people out of your restaurant
because you disagree with them
politically the answer is yes - do you
have the right to tweet about it the
answer is yes three do you have a right
to boycott that restaurant because of
that activity the answer of course is
yes now when are boycotts appropriate
well I think a boycott of the red hen
here is not inappropriate the reason
being that it's appropriate to boycott a
restaurant or a photographer or a baker
for that matter if they're private
political perspective translates over
into their business now I may not agree
with a particular boycott but I don't
think it's wildly inappropriate to
boycott I think it's inappropriate to
boycott chick-fil-a for example because
chick-fil-a doesn't actually
discriminate against anybody chick-fil-a
doesn't actually have any rules that
blow back on anybody so boycotting them
over the private views of their owner
seems to me completely counterproductive
and stupid boycotting the redhead over
what they did to Sarah Huckabee Sanders
or even boycotting a baker with whom I
did with whom I agree about same-sex
marriage for not catering a same-sex
wedding all of that seems to me within
the realm of permissible dialog all of
that makes a certain amount of sense
even if I agree with what one business
didn't disagree with what another
business did but instead what the left
has done is the left the left which says
that you should not be allowed the
government should force you the
government should force you to bake that
cake the government should force you to
make that pizza the government should
force you to photograph that wedding the
same left that says that says it's
wonderful that the business just kicked
out sarah huckabee sanders that i don't
understand at all to make that case
requires an amount of hypocrisy that is
well beyond the norm and even some folks
on the left are acknowledging this right
like the Washington Post editorial board
wrote a piece saying that people should
let Sarah Huckabee Sanders basically eat
where she wants to eat when they say we
nevertheless would argue that Miss
Huckabee and miss Nilson and mr. Miller
too should be allowed to eat dinner in
peace the reason they mentioned
Christian Nielsen is because something
else happened to Christian Nielsen I
want to talk about in just a second
she's the Secretary of Homeland Security
The Washington Post says those who are
insisting that we are in a special
moment justifying incivility should
think for a moment how many
Ekans might find their own special
moment how hard is it to imagine for
example people who strongly believe that
abortion is murder deciding the judges
or other officials who protect abortion
rights should not be able to live
peaceably with their families down that
road lies a world in which the only a
mozella sign up for public service that
benefits no one I think that's exactly
right from the Washington Post
shockingly they got this one right David
Axelrod tweeted something out that was
very similar he tweeted out that he was
appalled by Democrats sharing this he
said kind of amazed and appalled by the
number of folks on left who applauded
the expulsion of press secretary and her
family from a restaurant this in the end
is a triumph for Donald Trump's vision
of America now are divided by red plates
and blue plates
hashtag sad now the reality is this
stuff does benefit President Trump it
does benefit President Trump because
when you escalate these conversations to
the point of no return when you escalate
to the point when we can't have a civil
society together then trumpian punching
looks pretty good it looks pretty good
I'll give you an example so this was not
the worst example over the weekend there
were several examples of this sort of
uncivil boorish behavior over the
weekend so Kirsten Nielsen has happened
late last week she was eating at a
restaurant in Washington DC and a bunch
of protesters decided to crash the
restaurant wasn't the owners the owners
were fine with her eating they're a
bunch of outside protesters decided to
crash the restaurant and to yell at her
until she left and then she did leave
hey that was terrible and then Pam Bondi
who's the Florida Attorney General she
was spit on so left wing activist saw
Pam Bondi on the street and they started
chasing her down to harass her and spit
on here here's a little bit of what it
sounded like so what exactly did Pam
Bondi do that was so bad she went to a
screening of a mr. Rogers documentary no
I am not kidding she went to a screening
of a documentary on mr. Rogers the
leading advocate for civility over the
past half century the United States and
then left-wing activists came and
shouted her down so Christian Nielsen
the department of homeland security
secretary run out of a restaurant for
the great sin of working for the Trump
administration Sarah Huckabee Sanders
barred from a restaurant by the owners
for the great sin of working for the
Trump administration Pam Bondi screamed
at on the street for the great sin of
being a Republican and being in favor of
Rick Scott's policy on health care now
I will say that I think Huckabee Sanders
his situation is slightly different from
the Christian Nielsen and Pam Bondi
situations specifically because the
owner does have a right to keep people
out of their place well you don't have a
right so you actually do not have the
rights to walk into somebody else's
restaurants and harass somebody until
they leave right so just legally
speaking the people who showed up at the
restaurant with Christian Nielsen she
should have sat there and she should
have made the police come and arrest
those people and she shouldn't have left
she should have said to the restaurant
owners call the police because this is
harassment right this is actually a
violation of specific rights you are not
allowed to go into somebody else's place
of business and shut down the business
because you are having a problem with
one of the patrons who's patronizing
that business the worst example however
of incivility over the weekend was none
of these who was Maxine water so Maxine
Waters is just awful Maxine Waters is
indeed a she's been a for 30
years at least as long as I've been
following her in American politics I'm
only 34 years old and I remember when I
was very young
1992 LA riots I was eight years old and
Maxine Waters was out there calling it
the LA uprising and talking about how
necessary it was did a billion dollars
in property damage and ended with people
dead and she was talking about how
wonderful it was she's been just the
worst kind of politician in an American
public life for decades now well she
went out there and she was at the
federal building over on Wilshire
Boulevard and she was doing some events
and she started screaming and yelling
about why it is that we should now
harass people in their homes you should
shut people down Christian Nielsen by
the way protesters showed up outside her
home the Department of Homeland Security
Secretary they showed up outside her
home they were protesting the same thing
has happened to Chuck Schumer on
immigration right Democrats is happening
to you too but Maxine Waters loves this
stuff and so she's gonna push tactics
that are by any historical metric far
closer to brown shirt Nazi tactics than
anything the Trump administration has
done at the border
here's Maxine Waters
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I mean that's an insane statement
what she is talking about there is
essentially a fascist jackboot tactic
yeah I'm gonna review a section from a
great three-volume history of Nazi
Germany now again I'm not saying that
she is a Nazi I'm saying this is a Nazi
tactic okay it is a Nazi tactic to say
that you're going to get a bunch of
people together and you were going to go
harass public officials when they stop
at a gas station
hey that I'm not saying she's a Nazi
again I'm not saying her policies are
Nazi policies I'm saying this is a brown
shirt tactic because it is a far closer
tactic - brown shirt ISM then anything
that Trump has done at the southern
border including arresting people and
then by dint of 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals ruling separating kids from
parents I'm going to explain in a second
why I am NOT being shy about using a
Nazi analogy here because I think that
Nazi analogies are appropriate when you
can actually make the historical
reference point so I'm going to talk not
in big terms about what this reference
point is in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
Peter Millar look at this shirt this
magnificent shirt ok this shirt is just
the greatest shirt that I have ever it
really is a fantastic shirt and the
shirt comes courtesy of our friends over
at Peter Millar ok they started off as
providing clothing for golfers but
recently I've been receiving my style
tips from the clothing experts at Peter
Millar because Peter Millar stuff it's
quality its value its styled right now I
am wearing their performance polo and
what I love about these shirts is they
are just comfortable they're really
stylish is that I mean it's a
great-looking shirt I also have their
five pocket pants which are terrific
they're lightweight they are highly
breathable made from the highest quality
pima cotton and they have comfort
stretch for ease of movement I also have
a pair of shorts from Peter Millar and
they are just terrific
more than Disneyland yesterday they were
awesome they felt like your favorite
jeans with the style to be worn anywhere
do the five pocket pants and they appear
Millar's exclusive wash and finish to
enhance the softness they can be worn
year-round and since they are machine
washable they're easy to take care of
they really do look like the sort of
thing you'd have to dryclean but you
don't have to dryclean them they're
really terrific again the performance
polo fantastic sort of the five pocket
pants everything I get from Peter Millar
is top-notch I also have a shirt from
Peter Millar long sleeve shirt from
Peter Lila's just great Peter Miller
comm slash penny can check out some of
my Peter Millar favorites be sure to use
link and you will receive complimentary
shipping as well as a free hat so check
it out
Peter Millar mi ll AR comm slash man
that's Peter Mallard calm slash man once
again Peter Millar comm slash Ben they
are awesome there's a reason I wear
their clothing Peter Miller comm slash
Ben and when you use that slash Ben you
get complimentary shipping as well as a
free hat so when Maxine Waters says that
people should get out at gas stations
and they should shout no peace no sleep
no peace no sleep and when she says that
in a department store at a gas station
get out and you create a crowd and you
push back on them and you tell them to
not welcome anymore anywhere until
people they're not welcome in public
life that is in fact a fascist tactic
and then tactic it again I'm gonna say
it for the 30th time I'm not saying that
not that Maxine Waters is a Nazi I am
saying that this is a Nazi tactic it is
a fascist tactic there are people who
argue that fascism is only the
government that's coming in and and
using you know force to compel you to to
obey the government that's that's the
only definition of passion is what I'm
talking about here is a philosophically
culturally fascist tactic and that is
destroying the social fabric in the name
of politics by destroying every public
space and using violent means to shut
them down right auntie fush Utting down
speeches that's a fascist tactic and
this is a fascist tactic - this is
section from Richard Evans's book the
coming of the third wrath
considering the treatment of Social
Democrat Reichstag deputy Otto buck wit
in Silesia here's where it says brown
shirts this is a 1931 before the Nazis
took power so for those who say that
Nazism only oh you can only say Nazi
once somebody's in power in the
government that's just not true the
Nazis existed before they were in power
in the government here's what it says
brown shirts occupied the seats at his
meetings shouted insults at him and on
one occasion fired a shot at him causing
mass panic amongst his listeners and
leading to a brawl in which more shots
were fired by both stormtroopers and Rex
Bannerman several Nazis and Social
Democrats had to be taken to the
hospital and not a single table or chair
in the hall was left intact here we go
this is the part that's interesting
after this gangs of 8 to 10 Nazi storm
troopers harassed buckets outside his
house when he left for work in the
morning 20 or more crowded round him
when he came back to his office after
lunch and between 1 and 200 hassled him
on his way home singing a specially
composed song with words when the
revolvers are shot buck Wetzel cop the
watt Nazi demonstrators always halted
outside his house
death tube uh quits okay so harassing
people outside their homes bullying them
from gas stations bullying them from
restaurants these public confrontations
on politics these are a serious and
dangerous business so here is the basic
rule for a civilized society you have
the right to refuse service to anyone
you choose yes that applies to red hen
you have the right to criticize that
that restaurant you have the right to
protest any public official in a public
setting you do not have the right to
invade someone else's property to harass
someone dining in a public place or to
harass people at their homes as with
Christian Nielsen waters approach is way
worse than what happened at the redhead
now waters did is way worse than what
happened to Sarah Huckabee Sanders at
the redhead and every Democrat should be
asked on the record today
what Maxine Waters said about what
Maxine Waters said they should be asked
whether they agree with Maxine Waters
tactics here whether they think that
that is something that is half decent
because I promise you if this is a
Republican they be asked every single
time right when President Trump said
that at his rallies they he said one of
his rallies that if somebody punched a
protester that he paid for their legal
defense bill every Republican in the
country got asked about it and that was
wrong from shouldn't have said that well
any Democrat be asked today about Maxine
Waters his comments if not it just
demonstrates once again why you can't
trust the media now speaking of the
consequences of all of this I think
things could get a lot worse so it's not
just that protesters descended on DHS
Secretary Christian Nielsen's home it
turns out they are also threatening DHS
employees children DHS employees have
been warned that there have been
credible threats made against both them
and their children in a system-wide
email that also went out this weekend
from the department's Deputy Secretary
according to Emily Zanotti
over at the Daily wire which also
included a list of emergency services
and security protocols along with
information on how to access the
department's security force quote this
assessment is based on specific and
credible threats that have been levied
against certain DHS employees and a
sharp increase in the overall number of
general threats against DHS employees
although the veracity of each threat
varies in addition over the last few
days thousands of employees have had
their personally identifiable
information publicly released on social
media so is this the fault of Democrats
who are ratcheting up the rhetoric now
I'm not comfortable with saying the
democrats who are ratcheting up rhetoric
are responsible for threats of violence
or for violence itself unless you are
vertically calling for violence as
Maxine Waters appears to be doing that
I'm not going to blame you for violence
that takes place however is there any
question that the social fabric of the
country
decaying in real-time they are we're
watching people tear it and set it on
fire for political benefit no question
about that and it is it also true that
as the tenor of public debate grows and
grows as the as the fiery rhetoric grows
and grows that there are unbalanced
people who are going to do unbalanced
things it was a year ago
like literally about a year ago that a
Bernie Sanders fan decided to go shoot
up a congressional baseball game I know
well forgot about that but he attempted
to murder as many Republican Congress
people as he showed that wasn't Bernie
Sanders his fault but it is indicative
of the fact that we are raising the
temperature and when you raise the
temperature in the country you can't be
surprised when some frogs get boiled
right the the tenor of the country right
now is really really ugly protesters
outside Nielsen's home are apparently
unsatisfied that Nelson and the Trump
administration insist on enforcing
immigration laws even as the
administration reversed its policy on
separating detained adults from their
minor children while they await an
asylum hearing not only that there's a
story over the agents about leftist
protesters who are who are attempting to
basically storm an immigration facility
in McAllen Texas on Saturday according
to Fox News reporter Griff Jenkins about
200 protesters from the League of United
Latin American citizens were bussed ins
in McAllen facility from all areas of
Texas at one point when a bus carrying
illegal immigrants tried to leave the
facility the protesters surrounded
stopped the bus however during the melee
a Border Patrol agent attempting to
control the crowd was injured while
protecting an older woman Jenkins
reported according to the Daily Caller
news foundation that anchor that agent
suffered a broken ankle jenkins said
during the incidents protesters screen
set the children free and shame on you
two Border Patrol agents who eventually
helped maneuver the bus out of the
facility it was unclear where the bus
was headed a US Customs and Border
Patrol spokesman told CNN the immigrants
on the bus were being transferred to the
custody of ice agents again things
aren't getting violent and ugly out
there and they're going to get more
violent and more ugly when you have
people who are who are exaggerating the
case so you have a bunch of celebrities
who have decided that it's important for
the imperative for them to go down to
the border and grandstand on this issue
they're not making intelligent arguments
they're not interested in making
intelligence arguments they're not
interested in reason instead we are
getting a bunch of celebrities going
down to the bourse that they can pose
with signs they can prove to all of
their fans just how generous and
wonderful they are so Lena Dunham has
decided to go down to the border so she
and SIA
I don't know how anyone could tell it
was here because she saw her hair in
front of her face and amber
herd and other stars visited the border
city of Tornillo Texas to protest the
Trump administration's policy so in this
picture you can see it's kind of hard to
see them cuz they're wearing hats but
you can see Amber Heard I believe is on
the upper left there even see constants
whoo you can see let's see who else
bella thorne you can see I I believe is
that an is it Anna Kendrick down there
as well believe so
they're the SIA shows up again you're
not gonna recognize her because of her
crazy hair and then Lena Dunham of
course is there as well so you see a
bunch of folks on the left from
Hollywood who have decided it is
necessary to to go and do this routine
sorry not Anna Kendrick Kendrick Sampson
I don't want to get the wrong person
here Kendrick Sampson who I guess is a a
a TV guy he's on the flash I suppose so
a bunch of kind of quasi celebs go down
to the border to make a big deal out of
all this all this is going to do is
generate opposition on the other side
that a similar Mira Sorvino came out and
suggested this is just like pre Nazi
Germany again it's not like Nazi Germany
to storm restaurants and try and destroy
people's private lives
it is like Nazi Germany to enforce
immigration law apparently did you ever
think of it you would see that we are in
pre Nazi Germany the stages of things
that are occurring on a daily basis the
obfuscation the lies the totalitarian
behavior is shocking and horrendous yeah
so it's just like pre Nazi Germany again
this sort of rhetoric is is particularly
unhelpful if you were gonna make a Nazi
comparison you're actually gonna have to
bring the history when I make the Nazi
comparison to the tactic of shutting
down people's restaurants going
experiences and sitting outside their
houses to harass them that is closer to
a Nazi tactic then enforcing immigration
law as per the 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals okay and in just a second I want
to explain why this is all so dumb I
also want to talk a little bit about the
moral rule that we should apply in our
society because I think that the moral
ruled that we apply in our society is
not exactly the right one with regard to
how we treat others okay so Jay Johnson
here's here's the part that is
unbelievably stupid so none of this was
the reaction in 2014 his obama was
president so all of these democrats are
very upset all these leftist who are
very upset saying this is pre nazi
germany well still well many left to
start using nazi s tactics to shut down
people's dinner and
Sana's had their house and threatened
their kids Jay Johnson was the
Department of Homeland Security
secretary under Obama right he says
listen
of course we detained kids right this is
what we were doing what do you think we
were doing the whole time he says it's
to Chris Wallace on Fox News Sunday
without a doubt the images and the
reality from 2014
just like 2018 are not pretty and so we
expanded family detention we had then
34,000 beds for family detention only 95
of 34,000 equipped to deal with family
so we expanded it I freely admit it was
controversial we believed it was
necessary at the time a weird weird had
nothing happened because of that so
people say yeah there was media coverage
there was media coverage of it at the
time was it blanket like this where
their comparisons to the Japanese
internment camps in Nazi Germany
did you have celebrities jetting down to
the border other than Glenn Beck to hand
out actual soccer balls to some of the
kids who are being detained and then
who's being ripped right and left for
doing that only Jay Johnson gets away
with this because of course jeh Johnson
was a member of the grand and glorious
front of the Obama administration all of
this brings about a question and that is
what is the moral rule we got to apply
in our society so a lot of people are
big fans of the golden rule the golden
rule of course is stated in the jet and
the New Testaments they do unto others
as you would have them do unto you which
is sort of a variation on the old
testament rule love thy neighbor as
thyself
so do unto others as they would have
them do unto you there's another rule
that suggested by the Talmud and I would
suggest that this is a superior moral
rule at least when it comes to building
social fabric and that moral rule comes
courtesy of the the the elder Hillel so
there's a famous rabbi whose name was
hello and there's a famous story in the
Talmud it goes something like this there
is a guy who came to a famous rabbi
named Shammai and he said I want you to
teach me the entire Torah while I stand
here on one foot right he's trying to
mock shammai and sham I threw him out
and got angry at him and then he went to
Hillel who was famous for being a lot
more tolerant he went to hell oh and he
said I want you to teach me the entire
Torah meaning the entire Old Testament
philosophy while I stand here on one
foot and Hillel said back to him that
which is hateful to you do not unto
others the rest of it his commentary now
go and Lord right so you said that
that's the theme now there's a
difference between those two rules do
unto others is that you would have them
do unto you is not quite the same road
the Golden Rule as what's called the
silver rule which is that which is
hateful to you do not do unto others
okay I believe the silver rule is a
Rule four governing our relations in
public society then do unto others as
you would have them do unto you the
reason I think that it's a superior rule
is because do unto others as you would
have them do unto you
makes your standard of personal behavior
the standard for everyone else so what
you could say you could see a situation
in which you say listen if I were a Nazi
I hope that people would come to my
restaurant and shut me down if I were
working for Trump I hope that people
would come to my restaurant and shut me
down if I were pushing this immigration
policy I think that people totally
should threaten my kids right because do
one and I'll do unto others as I would
have them do unto me if I were a bad
person like that then I'd be fine with
that
right but the of the counter rule that
which is hateful to you do not do unto
others is not quite the same thing that
is it doesn't matter your moral status
or how you perceive yourself to be a
moral moral person a better person if
you don't like someone doing something
to you right now not as you perceive
yourself to be if you don't like
somebody doing something to you right
now
then you shouldn't do it somebody else
you don't like somebody shutting down
your dinner don't shut it down anybody
else's dinner if you don't like the idea
somebody's gonna threaten your kids
don't threaten somebody else's kids if
you're not a big fan of people
protesting you when you go to a gas
station
then you shouldn't protest people when
they go to gas stations the prohibitive
rule in my view is a much better rule
just in terms of interpersonal
relationships not community not
religious community relations I would
say the do unto others as you would have
them do unto you rule is very good for
communal relations in a religiously
like-minded community so my Jewish
community for example do unto others as
you would have them do unto you is a
fine rule because I would have people
give me charity so I should give them
charity or I would have people be kind
to my kids so I would be kind to their
kids but that's because we have a
general same view of the world if I
don't have the general same view of the
world as you then my inclination to use
the Golden Rule would be well if I were
as nasty as you I hope somebody would do
that to you but the silver rule says
doesn't matter how nasty I think you are
I don't want somebody doing that to me
they do not get to do that to they don't
get to do that to you all right that's
the silver rule so I'd say the silver
rule in social relations is actually
superior to the golden rule and this is
why and this is why now with all of that
said president Trump responds not by
calling us to the better inch of angels
of our nature but by being fully fully
Trump I mean dude is just unstoppable so
president Trump decides that he is going
to tweet out this is 14
he decides that he's going to tweet out
about the Red Hen situation regarding
Sarah Huckabee Sanders quote the redhead
restaurant should focus more on cleaning
its filthy canapes doors and windows
badly needs a paint job rather than
refusing to serve a fine person like
Sarah Huckabee Sanders I always had a
rule if a restaurant is dirty on the
outside it is dirty on the inside yep
just like just like Lincoln would've
done ripping into the ripping into the
paint job over at the Red Hen restaurant
because obviously he's never eaten there
isn't know anything about the redhead
but he knows that it looks dirty in the
pictures and if it looks dirty on the
outside it's dirty on the inside I just
I love that I wish he had the same
philosophy on porn stars but it's just
just just spectacular stuff from
President Trump right they're going
after the Red Hen dress right now is
that contributing to a great discourse a
great public discourse no of course it's
not contributing to a great public
discourse and this is part of the
problem you know I think that what
happened here is that the left really
thought the the reason they're so angry
right now is because the left truly
thought that after Obama they had
changed politics forever this was going
to be their thousand years of heaven
they were going to get there their
never-ending paradise after Obama won
and he had changed the face of politics
right we were never going to get a
Republican president again let alone a
Republican president and Republican
Congress let alone a Republican
president Republican Congress and
30-plus state legislatures and governors
who are Republican everything had
changed because of Obama and then the
ultimate anti Obama came in the form of
President Trump and he destroyed all
their dreams and they've lost it they've
just lost it and then President Trump
tends to exacerbate the loss of civic
culture okay I'm not going to sugarcoat
president Trump's behavior when it comes
to his additions to civic culture the
guy's not great for civic culture now I
understand people on the right or saying
well yeah he's punching back and there's
some truth to the idea that he is
punching back here but is this the way
that civic culture gets better does
civic culture get better because the
President of the United States is
tweeting about about the canopies over
at the red hen is that is that what
heals the country no of course not so
maybe you think the country is beyond
repair maybe you think the country is
beyond healing and all we can do it at
this point is just punch each other in
the face as hard as we can I don't think
it is I think that there is a a civic
engagement that needs to happen here but
it's not going to be led by the
leadership on either side apparently and
that's why in just a second I'm going to
talk about george will's latest column
which i think is too
totally wrong I'll get to that in just a
second first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire comm and subscribe so
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire this allows
you many privileges many great benefits
many great things will accrue to you
it's just a boon ok you get the rest of
this show live you get the rest of
Michel moles is awful show live you get
the rest of Andrew Clavin show live you
get all of those things live plus you
have to ask me questions in the mailbag
and when Jordan Peterson is here on July
on July 2nd you are going to get to ask
Jordan Peterson questions in the mailbag
as well because you're a subscriber and
when we have events like The Daily wire
live events that we're doing in August
in Dallas in Phoenix tickets still
available at Daley wire.com slash events
if you wanted the VIP tickets those are
all sold out but if you've been a member
you would have had first crack at those
tickets so becoming a member is really
great plus it helps support the show for
$99 a year you get all of those
magnificent privileges and you get this
the leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
you will love it it is wonderful and it
automatically refills apparently every
time Christian Nielsen goes to dinner or
something it's very weird it just sort
of spontaneously fills in my house I
have to keep have to keep pouring it out
it's bizarre but check it out you get
that with the 99 year it's the $99 a
year subscription which is cheaper than
the monthly also please go over to
SoundCloud please go over to youtube
please subscribe to our youtube channel
we have all sorts of great videos
constantly coming out we had a great
Sunday special last week with Jason
Whitlock our Sunday special next week is
going to be with Adam Carolla I believe
so it's gonna be just great and when you
subscribe then get to see that as well
so go check that out we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so George will came out with a column
that I think is utterly utterly
incorrect so George will in them in the
face of all of the incivility and all of
the trumpian politics of the moment and
he came out of the column that I think
is not just wrong I think it's frankly
quite stupid he came on the column
suggesting that people should not only
not vote Republican in the upcoming
congressional elections and will as a
lifelong Republican that they should
actually vote affirmatively for
Democrats this is nuts
this is nuts the same people who are
championing Maxine Waters his auntie
Maxine saying Maxine Waters is a
wonderful person she's auntie Maxine
right she's just a charmer Maxine Waters
you know the woman who pushed riots and
now is pushing people to harass people
at gas stations that lady's wonderful
that same party you should vote for them
to stop Trump okay if you're a
Republican and you believe this I think
it's fair to say that you've lost your
moorings the Trump is unmoored you as
well you've been so unmoored because you
can't deal with the cognitive dissonance
of a Republican running things who is
also President Trump and has all the
character flaws of President Trump you
become unmoored and this column is
unmoored so here's George well he says
amid the carnage of Republican Miss rule
in Washington there's this glimmer of
good news first of all where's the
carnage you know I just had to point
this out despite all of the crazy of the
news cycle and I'm the first to admit
this is crazy okay it's a new cycle
every 30 seconds President Trump has
been president for 111 years at this
point and he's only been president for a
year and a half not even a year and a
half the President of the United States
but we in the news business measure time
moving by news cycles and President
Trump does five news cycles a minute
I remember when Barack Obama was
president long ago it was one news cycle
a week it was always a crappy news cycle
now a lot of the news cycles are good
and some of the news cycles are bad but
it's a new news cycle every 35 seconds
but to read the Republican rule of
Congress as as carnage the economy is
hitting all-time highs were not in the
middle of any brutal Foreign Wars and
you're calling this carnage I just don't
get that he says the family shredding
policy along the southern border which
was merely the most telegenic recent
example of misrule clarified something
is George well occurring less than 140
days before elections that can reshape
Congress the policy has given
independence and temperate Republicans
these are probably expanding and
contracting cohorts respectively fresh
if redundant evidence for the principle
by which they should vote the principle
is the Congressional Republican caucuses
must be substantially
used not sure how you got that from the
immigration policy considering that
congressional Republicans wanted to fix
that immigration policy and Democrats
wants to release everyone so
substantially should they be reduced as
well that their remnants reduced to
minorities will be stripped of the
Constitution's article 1 powers they've
been to invertebrate to use against the
current wielder of article two powers
they will then have leisure times wonder
why they worked so hard to achieve
membership in a legislature whose
unexercised muscles have atrophied
because of people like them so he's
suggesting the Republican members of
Congress have failed because they have
not taken back legislative power I agree
in that sense I think the Republican
members of Congress should have seized
back executive power from the executive
branch while Obama was president I feel
they should do it right now when Trump
is president I think that the
legislature has abdicated its
responsibility for decades but if you
think that's getting fixed by Maxine
Waters Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
you got another thing coming and yet and
yet George will who again I think has
has lost it because of President Trump
continues along these lines is
considered The Melancholy example of
House Speaker Paul Ryan who wagered his
dignity on the patently false
proposition that it is possible to have
sustained transactions with today's
president this Vesuvius of mendacity
without being degraded and then he goes
into a long stick from a man for all
seasons
he says Ryan traded his political soul
for a tax cut he who formerly spoke
truths about the accelerating crisis of
the entitlement system lost everything
in the service of a president pledged to
preserve the unsustainable status quo
Ryan and many other Republicans have
become the president's poodles not
because James Madison system has failed
but because today's abject careers have
failed to be worthy of it and again I
don't disagree with this general
analysis of Congress I think this has
been true when Democrats were in
Congress when Republicans are in
Congress I think what we have watched
over the last 50 years in this country
is a dramatic acceleration of the
movement of power from article one to
article two from legislature to the
presidency but to suggest that the
solution again to this is to put
Democrats in charge is just ridiculous I
don't understand why the solution would
be like I understand their problems
within the GOP I've been talking at
nauseam about them for legitimately
years but to suggest that the solution
to that is that radical Democrats ought
to take over and then they will check
the power of the presidency by seizing
power back to the legislative branch
know what they will do is they will
immediately attempt to pass a bunch of
really bad bills that the federal
government
no business doing because there are two
things that the article one power is
supposed to grant you one is the power
to check other branches of government
and the Republican Congress isn't
exercising that but two is the article
one legislative power is supposed to
prevent the government from outgrowing
its prescribed size under the
Constitution itself the legislature is
supposed to be subject to popular rule
and that means they're not supposed to
run roughshod over the Constitution's
boundaries on the legislative power so
even if you believe the Democrats would
do a better job of checking the growth
of executive power they certainly would
not do a better job of preventing the
expansion of the federal government
that's fully insane the Democrats want
to expand the federal government at the
fastest rate in human history and yet
George will concludes that the
Republicans should be ousted he says in
today's GOP which is the president's
plaything he is the mainstream so to
vote against his parodies cowering
congressional caucuses is to affirm the
nation's honor while quarantine in him a
democratic-controlled Congress would be
a basket of deplorable 'z but there
would be enough Republicans to gum up
the Senate's machinery keeping the
institution as peripheral as it has been
under their control and is fixating
mischief from the Democratic house and
to those who say but the judges the
judges the answer is article 3
institutions are not more important than
those of article 1 and 2 combined but
his suggestion is that Democrats and
Republicans would fail to get anything
done in Congress but I thought that
tells him his complaint so now I'm
confused so he was saying that
Republicans aren't getting anything done
to check Trump's power in Congress but
then he suggests there will be enough
Republicans in Congress to prevent
Democrats from doing anything bad so is
his complaint that Congress is doing not
enough or that it is doing deal or that
it is doing too much again this is why I
say that I think everyone has been
completely debased by the Trump
presidency I think people have lost
their minds and they're spinning off in
a variety of different directions all of
which have nothing to do with the
reality of the situation the reality of
the situation is this president Trump's
governance itself is very mainstream
conservative or at least has been except
with regard to some peripheral issues
that are becoming central now like
tariffs but the governance itself been
pretty Republican president Trump's
manner has not been Republican his
manner has not been conservative his
manner has been trumpian and I
disapprove of a lot of it but but again
Democrats their response to that has not
been a return to normalcy the response
has been full-scale insanity I'm going
to talk about that in just a second
because
what I really believe right now is that
if Democrats were to run a candidate who
would run on a 1920 Warren G Harding's
style return to normalcy campaign Trump
would have some problems but Democrats
aren't capable of doing that because
Democrats are just too radical for all
of that so here's the proof of all of
this so Kamala Harris is now considering
running for president that of course is
not a shock she's a senator from the
state of California California is the
dumbest state in in the country I can
say that I've lived here my entire life
and Kamala Harris is an awful awful
senator she's not ruling out running for
president if the Democrats had any
brains at all they would run a candidate
who made people feel safe and secure and
solid because right now everything is
going really well in the country just in
terms of the economy and in terms of
foreign policy everything seems to be
going pretty decently but there is a
general feeling of unease about the
future of the country because of all the
crazy if the Democrats were to run
somebody reassuring they would have an
upper hand in 2020 I think but instead
they're going to run to the radical
intersectional left trying to please
that radical base that they think is
going to win them unerring victory and
unfailing and unfailing success in
coming campaigns Kamala Harris is an
intersectional candidate as radical as
they come and she's talking about
running for president in 2020 right now
I'm focused on on this I'm focused on a
lot of other things as a higher priority
but you're not ruling it out
you know okay so her not ruling it out
that's not shocking and wouldn't be
shocking if Democrats nominator because
that's what Democrats are looking to do
they're looking to move more and more
radical and this is why you get Trump so
as Democrats move more radical Trump
moves more radical as Trump moves more
radical Democrats move more radical and
what you're seeing right now is a
polarization of the parties now what's
funny about this is that Trump is
actually not all that radical in terms
of policy has been pretty straight lined
conservative but because he's juxtaposed
to a lot of weak-kneed Republicans he
looks strong to a lot of his base hey
take for example Jeff Flake so Jeff
Flake who's voted with President Trump
the vast majority of the time in
Congress he is opposing president
Trump's agenda on tariffs which i think
is correct there's a story out today
that harley-davidson is about to
offshore a bunch of their jobs right at
harley-davidson who Trump in 2017 just a
year ago claimed was the perfect case in
point for why we need tariffs is now
offshoring jobs due to president Trump's
tariffs on aluminum and steel they're
now taking all their jobs or a lot of
their jobs and they're moving them to
Europe because they sell about 40,000
motorcycles a year in Europe and they
can still read all of those motorcycles
in to the United States so Jeff Flake
doesn't like president Trump's tariff
policy which I agree with
but his solution to stopping Trump on
tariffs is to hold up a bunch of good
judges well where are the Republicans
saying well why don't we pass the judges
and also stop the tariffs where the
Republicans who are saying that they're
nowhere to be found so the Republican
Party is broke down into the people who
back everything Trump has done and the
people who are willing to hold up some
good parts of the agenda in order to
stop some bad parts of the agenda which
I don't understand at all here's Jeff
Flake making that case well I think
myself and a number of Senators at least
a few of us will stand up and say let's
not move any more judges until we get a
vote for example on tariffs how is that
even good policy doesn't make any sense
and then Jeff Flake goes even further he
says let's not attack Democrats on
immigration but Democrats program and
immigration has been made absolutely
crystal clear they want every illegal
immigrants in the country released this
is what they would like if they had
their druthers they they don't even
really want serious border checks they
want catch and release to be reinstated
and but Jeff Flake says let's not attack
Democrats on immigration like this is
why people go to trump because even
moderate Republicans can't hold it too
long enough to make the case or even
straight line Republicans can't hold it
together long enough to make the case
that Trump's Judge pics are good but his
tariffs are bad I don't understand why
any of this is particularly tough but
Jeff Flake apparently can't figure it
out Congress has to fix this and what is
bothersome is the president's rhetoric
about the Democrats and their
unwillingness to to have any type of
border security or control they are on
record supporting significant border
control they have turned down every deal
on border control that trump has ever
presented them with Trump presented them
with a deal on border control that have
provided like a basic minimum funding
for the wall wouldn't paid for the whole
wall bite by any stretch of the
imagination and it would have provided
some more security for Customs and
Border Patrol but it would have allowed
1.8 million illegal immigrants right 1.8
million dreamers and unregistered
dreamers to become essentially citizens
to join a pathway to citizenship the
Democrats turned that down
so Jeff Flake is just wrong this is why
George will is wrong Jeff Flake is wrong
the Democrats are increasingly radical
and surrendering to Democrats is not the
solution he can stand up to Trump's
heresies while at the same time praising
the stuff that he does well and if you
fail to do that then all you are doing
is driving people into Trump's arms on
the stuff that is more heretical and
driving more people into Democrats arms
on the stuff that is not heretical it's
it's just it's not good all the way
around and again I think it's it's being
contributed to by a tremendous amount of
anger in the public discourse all of
which is is really really dangerous okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so today's
things I like there's a great book by
Gerald Green called the last angry man
who's made into a movie by a movie with
up home unis it was his last movie and
the last angry man is about general
Green's dad basically it's about a TV
producer cuz Gerald Green wrote for TV
who comes back and he's talking to he
comes back to Brooklyn and he's talking
to this old doctor who sort of is he's
an angry guy he's angry society he's
angry at dirts in society but he cares
for everybody in the society and his
anger is what makes him unpalatable for
TV because they want to see happy
smiling faces and he's angry at the
status of society while at the same time
taking care of people well the last
angry man is what we need more of in
America and I don't mean more angry I
mean people who are angry but also
capable of taking care of others because
I think right now our anger
is channeling itself not toward making
the country better but toward making the
country worse I think all of the anger
that is right now being directed at the
Trump administration if you don't like
what the Trump administration is doing
by all means go down to the border and
bring some actual resources for the kids
who are down at the border but if your
solution is that you're gonna go down to
the border and shout about Nazis or
you're gonna go down to Christian
Nielsen's restaurants and throw her out
of her restaurants or go to her house
and yell at her outside her house none
of this is productive people are not
righteously indignant at this point they
are full righteously indignant which
means that they are using anger as the
fuel for all of the bad stuff that they
want to do and then claiming their
righteous on the surface that's not the
kind of anger that we need yes we should
all be angry at societal injustice --is
like real societal injustice is but the
solution to that should be to work to
rectify those in justices not to scream
and shout and be uncivil and be nasty
and be stupid and all of that is deeply
counterproductive okay time for a couple
of things that I hate so have you ever
had Little House on the Prairie I
remember growing up I read Little House
on the Prairie and I thought that it was
quite a good book because it's been
famous for a very long time they made a
series of it it's really terrific right
everybody who grew up watching Michael
lands in in Little House on the Prairie
a lot of folks right I got a couple of
hands in the studio and we only have
three other people in the studio right
now my two out of the three watched
Michael lands in the Little House on the
Prairie
now the association of library service
to children board voted this weekend to
change the title of their annual Legacy
Award for Excellence in children's
literature away from the Laura Ingalls
Wilder award instead they will change to
the children's literature Legacy Award
why because Wilders work includes
expressions of stereotypical attitudes
inconsistent with a CLC's ALCS is sorry
core values the change reportedly
received a standing ovation from the
Chicago based organization why because
they objected to Wilders works being
widely read and promoted because they
said her her legacy was complex and not
universally embraced why well because
she was considered controversial and not
woke enough she speaks of her family's
fear of Native American attacks and she
had ear asipi use on blacks right
intellectuals and historians might teach
Wilders works in the context of her
upbringing but apparently children's
librarians are incapable of the same
level of nuance again who has read
Little House on the Prairie and came
away a racist who hates Native Americans
like really I'm lacking the words for
this exactly now I read it and I'm
Wonder
like if you watch that show with michael
lenz did you come away and you were like
man i am so glad the Trail of Tears
happened like is anyone like is there
anyone who felt that way the answer of
course is no but we have to assume the
full-on stupidity of the American public
and we have to assume that when
children's children read Laura Ingalls
Wilder than one reinstitute slavery
because they read about a little family
a settler family on the Prairie clearly
that was the main thrust of her books
now all of this is stupid we are going
to wipe away any past look here's the
reality in a hundred years people will
think we're barbarians and a hundred
years people are gonna look back on us
and I think there are probably two areas
of American life where people will think
that we are barbarians when they look
back on us one is in the area of
abortion I think in a hundred years
people look back and they'll say wow
this society was celebrating the murder
of the unborn that is nuts because the
science progresses is becoming clearer
and clearer that is just an insanely non
human rights position and then I think
that there's a high probability that a
hundred years from now and we've
developed better science for the
development of meat and meat substitutes
people will look at the treatment of
animals in our society and they'll say
that was really inhumane I think there's
a good shot that that happens but does
that mean all the literature from today
should be immediately cast out because
in virtually every book there's somebody
eating steak I look how they treated the
animals in that book well these should
keep dogs as pets but now we know how
smart dogs are we would never let dogs
be pets you could see this happening in
a hundred years because we're doing it
now with stuff that happened 200 years
ago how about this how about we assume
the literature from the past was written
at that time and then we take that for
granted and then we and then we look
into that when we read the stories and
then we can make distinctions because
that's what human beings do on a regular
basis okay other things that I hate one
more thing that I hate and then we'll
get to a Federalist paper real fast so
there's this really idiotic idea that
all cultures are created equal all
cultures are not equivalent okay here is
the proof of that little obvious
statement which I know is deeply
controversial in today's society we have
to assume that all cultures are created
equal so late last week science magazine
archeology writer Lizzie Wade released a
report on the shocking scale of human
sacrifice among the Aztecs for
generations students have wondered at
the horrifying tales of priestly murder
among the Aztecs the removal of the
heart still beating from a living
person's torso the decapitation of the
corpse and the creation of literally
racks of skulls to be placed of what is
called I'm gonna mispronounce this but
it's called the Tanakh titling
tzompantli
which is now buried under Mexico City
Mexico City is over the site when the
Spanish reached this site they saw this
barbarity and they promptly raised the
the entire the the the tzompantli was I
guess at these giant racks of human
skulls like literally thousands and
thousands of racks of human skulls so
they raised all of that and they knocked
down a couple of the Aztec pyramids and
then they basically built on top of it
now according to this author over at
science some conquistadors wrote about
the tzompantli and its towers estimating
the rack alone contained a hundred and
thirty thousand skulls historians and
archaeologists knew the conquistadors
were prone to exaggerating the horrors
of human sacrifice to demonize the
Mexico culture as the centuries passed
scholars began to wonder whether this
had even other existed and whether
whether this had existed in the first
place but archaeologists at the National
Institute of anthropology and history
now say with certainty it did beginning
in 2015 they discovered and excavated
the remains of the skull rack and one of
the towers underneath the colonial
period house on the street that runs
behind Mexico City's Cathedral the other
tower they suspect lies hundred
cathedrals back courtyard the scale of
the rack and tower suggests they held
thousands of skulls testimony to an
industry of human sacrifice unlike any
other in the world an imposing
rectangular structure 35 metres long 12
to 14 meters wide slightly larger than a
basketball court unlikely five to four
to five meters high from their knowledge
of the era of the templo mayor which is
the the giant pyramids archeologists the
ziggurats estimate that the particular
phases of the tun patently they found
were likely built between 1486 and 1502
although human sacrifice have been
practiced since its founding in 1325
here and here's the point
all pre-modern societies make some kind
of offering Tulane University bio
archaeologist John Verano says and in
many societies if not all the most
valuable sacrifices human life about 75%
of the skulls examined so far belonged
to men most between the ages of 20 and
35 prime warrior age little side note
how could they tell there were the
skulls meant how did they identify how
dare they but twenty percent were women
five percent belonged to children so
five percent of all these skulls were
kids when they were cutting the living
hearts out of than decapitating so good
times over there our culture has a
really nasty habit of romanticizing all
things that are foreign to
judeo-christian and civilization a lot
of those things kind of suck
turns out human sacrifice is one of
those things and the Bible is very anti
human sacrifice that doesn't mean that
when the Spanish got to the New World
they treated people humanely they did
not it does not mean that they were
justified and all of their action they
were not but listen to the way that
science magazine writes nests for the
Aztecs the larger cultural group to
which the Mexico belong those skulls
were the seeds that would ensure the
continued existence of humanity they
were a sign of life and regeneration
like the first flowers of spring but the
Spanish conquistadors who marched into
ten explan in 1519 saw them differently
for them the skulls and the entire
practice of human sacrifice events the
Mexico's barbarism and justified laying
waste to the city in 1521 okay I don't
know whether it's justified to lay waste
to an entire city I'm gonna go now but
is it kind of art para - I don't know
chop the heads off children yeah yeah
kind of barbaric not all cultures are
created equal in every way this is not
merely a cultural difference I think we
can say with certainty that certain
things are objectively worse than other
things and human sacrifice is one of
those things if you've never seen the
movie Apocalypto which is Mel Gibson's
underrated work it is a an excellent
take on this exact issue is well worth
watching okay time for a quick
Federalist paper so we are all the way
up to Federalist 34 we are making steady
progress through the Federalist Papers
this one is again by Alexander Hamilton
here at the vast majority of the
Federalist Papers and this one continues
to deal with the issue of federal
taxation and why it is the federal
government should be able to be given
taxing power because there are a lot of
folks in the States you said once you
give the federal government taxing power
they will never stop that of course
ended up being largely correct he argues
that of course the feds have to have
taxing power because they may have to do
more in terms of defense he says to form
a more precise judgment of the true
merits of this question it will be well
to advert to the proposition to the
sorry adverts the proportion between the
objects that will require a federal
provision in respect to revenue and
those which will require a state
provision we shall discover the former
are altogether unlimited in other words
it will cost more to run the federal
government because we have to fight wars
and the latter are circumscribed within
very moderate bounds so that's why we
don't have specific limits on the amount
of taxation that the federal government
can participate in
he says the feds will mostly spend on
defense and here is the key for all
those people who say today that we spend
too much money on defense but we don't
spend enough money on social services
the founders thought precisely the
opposite they thought that the central
function of the federal government was
defense and social services were best
left to the states and localities if at
all and here is what Hamilton writes is
one of the chief sources of expense in
every government what is occasioned that
enormous accumulation of debts with
which several of the European nations
are
the answer is plainly wars and
rebellions the support of those
institutions which are necessary to
guard the body politic against these two
moral diseases of society
he says the expenses arising from those
institutions which are relative to the
mere and domestic police of a state to
the support of its legislative executive
and judicial apartments and juda and
judicial departments with their
different appendages and to the
encouragement of agriculture and
manufacturers are insignificant in
comparison with those which relate to
the National Defense in other words all
your other functions those are not going
to be nearly as much as you spend on
national defense this is why when you
hear people say that the founders when
they said general welfare meant the
government ought to spend lots and lots
of money on social services no the
founders never believed this they never
thought this and they would be appalled
at the size and scope of the federal
government okay we'll be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing